AYAKA: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERVIEWER: Ayaka
is in love with Cain,
a character in
"100 Day Princess,"
a simulated dating app targeted
at women in their 20s and 30s.
AYAKA: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERVIEWER: The
game is about a girl
who becomes a princess
while wearing a glass
slipper for 100 days.
The user plays the
role of the princess.
The game was created by Cybird,
one of many companies producing
these types of apps.
LENA: The term
virtual boyfriend is
what's most commonly
used in US media outlets,
but most of our fans
don't use that term.
They will refer to
the genre they're
playing as an otome
game, or some of them
might call it a romance
game or a love sim.
Otome game when
literally translated
means a meet in
game-- just basically
a game for young women.
INTERVIEWER: In an otome
game, the usual objective
is to fall in love.
Users can often have multiple
boyfriends at one time
and decide on interactions
with boyfriends that
decide the fate of the game.
Otome games have fueled
the thriving mobile gaming
industry, which accounts
for nearly $6 billion
of the Japanese gaming market.
LENA: Otome games are definitely
our biggest strength right now.
What sets otome games
apart is definitely
the amount of reality that
we bring to all of our games.
You really do feel like you're
falling in love with somebody,
and you also feel
like this really
could happen to me
some time, even if it's
outside of this virtual world.
INTERVIEWER: Games contain
complex plots written
by a team of predominately
female writers,
and the storylines get creative.
Other companies
have released games
where users can date
samurais, historical figures,
or even pigeons, like
in one game called
"Hatoful Boyfriend."
Cybird is hoping its US version
of "100 Day Princess," known
as "Midnight Cinderella,"
will also become a hit.
LENA: We've had about 1.3
million downloads since we
released it two years ago.
This is a fantasy
slash romance app
where you become the
princess of a kingdom,
and your first job is
to find your prince.
There are nine really hot guys
that you get to choose from,
and over the course of
the game, you fall in love
and find out whether or not
your romance is going to last
or not.
NATUSKO: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERVIEWER: Simulation games
gained popularity in Japan
in the 1980s, but the first one
designed specifically for women
was released in 1994
named "Angelique."
It was made for Super
Nintendo, and it
set the precedent
for women's games
in this genre to
focus on romance.
LENA: I think it can be a
great stress reliever when
you're playing these games.
It's really, really
nice to have a guy who
lives in your cell
phone who only comes out
when you want him to.
He loves you unconditionally.
He's just the perfect guy.
AYAKA: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERVIEWER: And
although some may
be quick to write
off otome games
as a quirky Japanese
subculture, the genre
is becoming immensely popular
in the United States, as well.
LENA: Our American
audience has been
exposed to Japanese
anime and manga
from a very, very young age.
About 15 to 20 years ago,
"Sailor Moon" and "Pokemon"
really made a big impact on a
lot of young people's lives.
So they can really relate to
the characters in the game,
and they feel comfortable
with the illustration style.
I think within the
next 5 to 10 years
this is going to be a very, very
popular genre that most people
know about and will be playing.
INTERVIEWER: With such loyal fan
bases comparable with cult TV
shows, otome games
may just become
another feature of a
typical modern woman's life.
AYAKA: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
LENA: I personally feel that
this is just an evolution
of the romance novel genre.
I think as people are
shifting away from reading
and not buying
books, and they're
spending a lot more of their
leisure time on their phones
or on tablets, and
that's where they
get their romantic
satisfaction from.
INTERVIEWER: Be sure to watch
this next episode, which
looks at how a website helping
young couples book hotel rooms
is shaking up
conservatives in India.
SUBJECT: [INAUDIBLE]
of confidence
in these people
[INAUDIBLE] we work
with are going to be very safe.
There will be no
questions asked,
and they'll be given a safe
space. [INAUDIBLE] safe in all.
INTERVIEWER: Thanks for
watching "Seeker Stories"
and be sure to subscribe
for new videos every week.